herr lauterbach wie kann man sich das
jetzt vorstellen wir sind auf der einen
seite in der forderung einen lock down
zu verschärfen und haben auf der anderen
seite die situation eben vor allen
dingen die alten schützen zu müssen und
uns um die besonders kümmern zu müssen
weil die mutation natürlich auch die sie
weiter vor allen dingen eben betreffen
wird ja das stimmt also man muss
wirklich sagen mal den menschen sagen
was ist moment das große problem in den
altenheimen müssen wir besser werden
lasst uns einfach ohne wenn und aber so
und zwar müssen dort die tests von
menschen gemacht werden die nicht im für
das altenheim arbeiten das könnt ihr
nicht erbringen die alten hand
beschäftigten die pflegeheim
beschäftigten die pflegekräfte
sie können nicht auch noch besucher
testen oder sich selbst jeden tag testen
sondern das muss gemacht werden auch die
bestellungen müssen für diese
pflegeeinrichtung gemacht werden das
muss deutlich besser organisiert wenn da
noch viel luft nach oben
aber das wird selbst wenn die
pflegeeinrichtungen noch so gut schützen
das wird den jetzt notwendigen
verschärften shutter und aus meiner
sicht nicht überflüssig machen
die menschen die es auf der
intensivstation also um ihr leben ringen
das ist trauriger weise selten jemand
noch da aus dem pflegeheim kommt diese
leute kommen lassen schon gar nicht mehr
in die intensivstation sondern die
sterben in den pflegeeinrichtungen
das durchschnittsalter in den großen
intensivstationen liegt derzeit bei 60
jahren das ist doch sehr viele jüngere
menschen über uns sehr viel also sehr
viele jüngere menschen die übergewicht
haben übergewicht zahlt sich immer aus
allein immer stärker risikofaktor für
schwerste verläufe die dann oft über
wochen hinweg dort beatmet werden müssen
das heißt man darf die zeit gar nicht
viel interpretieren dass die menschen
auf den intensivstationen jünger werden
sollen weil die älteren eben in den
pflegeeinrichtungen auch wenn wir die
werden wir wählen der ersten welle die
menschen aus den pflegeeinrichtungen
noch alle in die auf die
intensivstationen bringen würden dann
wären die intensivstation schon längst
überlaufen
wir sind jetzt dazu übergegangen war das
auch so eine schlechte sterblichkeit
hatte da sind ja von den pfleger haben
also bewohnern die ihn auf die
intensivstation kamen selbst bei bester
pflege also ich kenne und der besta
intensivversorgung also und auf den
modernen intensivstationen die wir hier
haben charité und weiter da stirbt man
nicht leicht
da kann man fast jeden durchbringen aber
die also menschen aus pflegeheimen sind
dort gestorben daher wird das heute gar
nicht mehr versucht und jetzt kämpft man
wirklich um das alter der großen gruppe
der baby boomer die risikofaktoren haben
und das halten wir nicht mehr lange
durch das sind sehr schwere fälle ok
dann gehen wir noch mal nach göttingen
zu frau professor thomas und fragen noch
mal nach den alten menschen frau
professor
die zahlen zeigen corona ist eben
überwiegend eine krankheit und eine
todbringende krankheit der alten kommt
die impfung deshalb dafür viele einfach
zu spät wenn wir so weitermachen wie wir
jetzt agieren
ich muss mal korrigieren es nicht
überwiegend eine krankheit der alten die
meisten betroffenen sind junge leute
zwischen 20 und 30
aber diese erkrankung meistens nicht so
schwer die sind krank zu hause bleiben
und sie genesen wieder
aber die alten menschen die erkrankten
schwer und sterben daran
und von daher ist die strategie jetzt ja
eben vordringlich alte menschen und
vordringlich auch alte menschen in
diesen gemeinschaftseinrichtungen wo so
schwer abstände und hygieneregeln
einzuhalten sind zu impfen und das ist
richtig so sollten menschen in den
heimen sind sehr dankbar darum die
freuen sich riesig wenn wir kommen ja
die eben eine todbringende krankheit ist
ist zuallererst eben für den die alten
menschen auf welche das wollte ich
fragen auf welche reaktionen stoßen sie
und müssen sie auch viel
überzeugungsarbeit leisten bei ihren
einsätzen bei den alten menschen sehr
wenig diesen ganz überwiegend wirklich
froh und dankbar und sagen das auch so
sie dazu in der lage sind
überzeugungsarbeit leisten müssen wir
manchmal bei den pflegekräften
obwohl ich auch da fiel ja wirklich
entgegenkommen und überzeugung gesehen
habe zwar jetzt nicht mein eindruck dass
sich der pflegekräfte in großer zahl
weigern sich impfen zu lassen obwohl es
diese zahlen gibt wenn man dorthin fährt
zumindest hier in der stadt sind es sehr
viele die da auch bereit sind sich
impfen zu lassen und das für sehr
wichtig halten gehen wir noch mal nach
drei jahren frage nach impfung ist
sie ist sehr groß und es gibt jeder
kennt glaube ich mehr menschen die es
sich wünschen geben wir noch mal nach
dresden zu michael kretschmer sachsen
ist nach nordrhein westfalen
herr kretschmann nach thüringen und nach
baden württemberg viertletzter beim
impfen warum ist das so warum ist
sachsen auch da in anführungsstrichen
leider ein trauriger sie müssen sich
anschauen welche homöopathischen dosen
am anfang ausgeliefert wurden zum
verhelfen und die kollegen die dafür
zuständig sind haben das zum teil
gebündelt damit das stand in ganzen heim
verwendet werden kann und man nicht mit
kleinen gruppen los fährt das ist ein
anfangs effekt der muss besser werden
aber am ende geht es glaube ich darum
dass wir uns alle miteinander deutlich
machen und das ist der kernpunkt wenn in
der bevölkerung des virus zu weit
verbreitet ist dann trägt es sich
überall hin in die schulen in die
betriebe in die pflegeheime und dieses
virus ist so typisch weil viele auch
keine symptome haben und es so hoch
ansteckend ist dass sie dann keinen
wirkungsvollen schutz mehr auch für ein
pflegeheim bei bester besten wissen und
gewissen gewährleisten können und
deswegen müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
die verbreitung in der bevölkerung
reduziert wird nur dann können wir durch
diese zeit kommt das ist der grund warum
wir jetzt mit darüber sprechen müssen ob
die maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben
wirken wir sehen das ist nicht überall
der fall und deswegen geht es ums nach
steuern von den dingen die wir gesehen
haben dass sie funktionieren pflegeheime
wirklich nur noch betreten mit negativen
schnelltest einen aktionsradius von 15
kilometer zum einkaufen und zum sport
machen diese dinge die wir jetzt auch
gesagt haben kinder nur noch in der not
betreuung im kindergarten das sind die
wichtigen dinge um einfach weniger
kontakte weniger mobilität zu erzeugen
dann kann uns das gelingen und das ist
eine vorbereitung auf diese mutation und
es ist eine entlastung der krankenhäuser
die heute ganz oft schon unter volllast
arbeiten
er gewann kam bei ihnen dem moment des
nachdenkens darüber und des darüber
nachsinnen dass man vielleicht nicht
immer und in jeder
situation auf die gegner von maßnahmen
hören sollte man kam das war nie mein
antrieb mein antrieb das dass diese dass
man der situation angemessen handeln wo
es im sommer haben wir bei uns eine ganz
niedrige instituts gehabt 345 und da war
es richtig sie menschen die möglichkeit
zu geben zu gesellschaftlichen zu
wirtschaftlichen handelns und dann haben
wir im oktober diese verstärkung gehabt
auf die wir zu spät aus meiner sicht
reagiert haben und erst bei mir war es
das erleben auf intensivstationen in den
ich gesehen habe diese menschen diese an
die dort arbeiten die ich sind am ende
ihrer kräfte und das schon seit fünf
sechs wochen das geht so nicht weiter
und auf der anderen seite eine
gesellschaftliche stimmung die darin
bestand dass die leute mir nur gesagt
haben was sie an öffnungen haben wollten
was sie an erleichterung haben wollten
und das habe ich für mich gesehen das
geht so nicht gut und deswegen bleibt am
ende eben nicht eigenverantwortung und
die die freiheit sondern tatsächlich
sehr starke restriktive maßnahmen die
aus meiner sicht jetzt auch in sachsen
ihre wirkung entfalten war die situation
im oktober nicht aber auch eine wo unter
anderem auch der sächsische
ministerpräsident dafür plädiert hat
nicht gleich die maßnahmen umzusetzen
die die kanzlerin empfahl und übrigens
könnte man im nachhinein vielleicht auch
das sagen was ihr ministerpräsidenten
kollege sagte menschen neigen dazu immer
den leichteren weg oder den vielleicht
hoffnungsvollen weg zu gehen ich stehe
ja selber dass ich mich auch von dieser
hoffnung ableiten lassen und ich muss
heute sagen es ist falsch
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass ich früher
gewarnt worden wäre
auf vermerke allein darf man sich nicht
verlassen dann geht es schief
also herr krieg war warum klingt es bei
ihnen so kompliziert warum hätten sie
nicht einfach sagen können es war ein
fehler werten ohne recht weil sie ein
zitat verwendet haben
was diesen text hat ich habe schon im
dezember gesagt dass das ein fehler war
muss man sich immer klar machen
die maßnahmen die wir die wirklich eine
wirkung entfalten sind die die den hafen
lockdown beschreiben und jetzt ist die
frage war die situation in deutschland
in sachsen in deutschland im oktober so
hätten wir die durchhaltefähigkeit
gehabt um das ganze wirklich über monate
zu bringen das ist eine
abwägungsentscheidung die man treffen
muss
sie haben recht mit dem wissen von heute
während andere entscheidungen notwendig
gewesen deswegen habe ich auch damals
immer gesagt schon im dezember
das war ein fehler so ist die frage wenn
wir einen fehler gemacht hat was folgt
daraus jetzt für die zukunft und
deswegen glaube ich einen in ruhe
hinsetzen in der kommenden woche und
ganz offen die situation betrachten wir
sind in deutschland nicht an dem punkt
wo wir hin wollten und wir haben eine
bedrohung die auf uns zukommen die nach
der grünen die noch die auf uns zu kommt
jedoch erst gekommen und deswegen müssen
wir jetzt die maßnahmen überprüfen und
nachschärfen
ich habe ein paar punkte gesagt die aus
meiner sicht da notwendig sind und das
wird denke ich auch nächste woche das
nächste woche passieren
machen wir erstmal weiter mit der frage
eckart von hirschhausen wie bei ihnen
die empfehlung von markus söder an kamen
über eine impfpflicht nachzudenken also
medizinisches personal pflegepersonal
ist offensichtlich auch zurückhaltend in
bezug auf das sich impfen lassen
was halten sie davon doch über eine
fläche nachzudenken
das ist in der fachwelt völlig klar dass
es unsinnig ist
das ist nicht nur ein phänomen von
virologen und epidemiologen es geht auch
ganz viel um psychologie und
kommunikation ich habe ja auch
wissenschaftsjournalisten studiert ich
habe mich mit cornelia betsch
unterhalten die in erfurt die kosten
studie leitet die auch
ganz klar schon bei der masern impfen
sagte in dem moment wo man menschen zu
etwas zwingt hat das viele negative
effekte an anderer stelle zum beispiel
sinkt die zustimmung für freiwillige
impfung im fall der nase und deswegen
war das auch schon überhaupt diesen
begriff impfpflicht ins rennen zu
bringen war aus heutiger sicht meinen
augen unnötig weil die meisten menschen
wenn man es ihnen gut erklärt verstehen
dass impfen sozial ist ist es
solidarisch es geht um gruppen
schutzgemeinschaft schutz ich mag auch
diese wort herdenimmunität kein mensch
isst gerne teil einer herde sie stimmt
übrigens ja also wir sollten uns
angewöhnen gemeinschaft sozusagen
gemeinschaftsschule ist häufig so klingt
als hier sehen so weit ist es sicher ist
es solidarisch ist eine der genialsten
dinge die wir in der medizin haben und
deswegen ist es eine maßgebliche fragen
von aufklärung von gesundheitskompetenz
und eben auch kommunikationsstrategien
menschen zum beispiel auch in ihren
berufsgruppen anzusprechen ich habe
heute mit christine vogel auf die vize
präsidentin vom deutschen pflegerats
gesprochen die ich vom deutschen
pflegetag kenne und die sagte auch es
ist völlig falsch
pflegefachkräfte in die nähe von von
corona leugnern zu bringen das ist
überhaupt nicht der fall
aber es findet viel zu wenig
kommunikation eben auch fachspezifische
statt es gibt werbekampagnen auf der
einen seite ärmel hoch und so es gibt
aber bis heute noch keine richtig gute
evidenzbasierte entscheidungshilfe und
dafür würde ich mich sehr stark machen
in dem land und wir sind genau bei der
frage warum und ob es eben vielleicht
auch gute gründe gibt da zurückhaltend
zu sein und bedenken zu haben und was
von dem was wieder zu hören stimmt
schauen sie mal
auf diesen peaks richtet sich die
hoffnung rekordverdächtig schnell wurde
der impfstoff entwickelt sehnlich
erwartet aber auch kritisch beäugt
skepsis ausgerechnet in der altenpflege
die nebenwirkungen sind vielleicht auch
noch nicht so ganz klar
und da sind viele junge leute sind da
zufällig in heimen wird am meisten
gestorben
er sieht deshalb keine zeit zu zögern
was für masern recht muss für corona
billig sein heißt es aus bayern eine
kurve impfpflicht für die pflege
wenn wir dort spüren und hören und lesen
dass sehr wenige der pflegekräfte sich
impfen lassen zu wenige dann müssen wir
darüber diskutieren
die reaktion folgt dass die mitarbeiter
kein verständnis dafür haben wenn jetzt
plötzlich mit einer impfpflicht quasi
gedroht wird
wir brauchen einfach mehr aufklärung
aufklärung oder impfpflicht in der
altenpflege die debatte hat erst
begonnen
michael kretschmer die pflegenden die
eben in den pflegeheimen und altenheimen
sind egal ob ärzte oder medizinisches
personal müssten natürlich genauso ein
interesse daran haben geschützt und
gesund zu sein muss man über seine
pflicht nicht wenigstens nachdenken ja
ich sehe das so wir schauen jetzt lassen
sie uns erst mal der aldi impfen die das
wollen wir das hingekriegt haben dann
reden wir weiter
ich denke auch dass das auch noch einen
erfahrungs prozess ist natürlich gibt es
bedenken und sorgen aber das wird sich
ja im zeitverlauf aufklären das ist aus
meiner sicht absolut richtig beschrieben
wenn man mit so etwas droht machen die
leute zu und an dem punkt sind wir jetzt
noch gar nicht wir wollen die älteren
jetzt impfen hintereinander weg ich
erlebe er gerade medizinischen personal
einen großen wunsch und den des drängen
bringt uns jetzt den impfstoff und das
wird sich dann auch rumsprechen herr
lauterbach für die wahl
die entscheidung ist natürlich auch
entscheidend dass der impfstoff am ende
kann und ob er nur vor einer schwersten
erkrankung schützt in anführungsstrichen
nur oder ob er tatsächlich auch die
infektion zurück drängen kann wann
werden wir das wissen über die
impfstoffe werden wir in wenigen wochen
wissen also wenig wissen über uns dass
die impfstoffe nicht nur vor schwersten
erkrankungen schützen sondern auch vor
schweren erkrankung schützen das ist
also schon mal eine menge wissen aber in
ein paar wochen werden wir wissen ob es
auch zum schutz vor infektionen kommt es
wird sehr detailliert jetzt in israel
ausgewertet wo man quasi auf test basis
genau dieser frage nachgeht und das
werden wir rasch raus haben meine
vermutung ist die dass die impfstoffe
nicht komplett vor der infektion
schützen sondern dass du hast du
vielleicht so ein schutzfaktor von 60
prozent seien vielleicht etwas mehr
etwas weniger und zwar deshalb weil die
art der immunität in den schleimhäuten
also wo man sich ansteckt das ist eine
andere art der immunität als die
immunität die im blut sich abspielt und
den tieferen also in atemwegen somit
also wäre es eine überraschung wenn es
an kompletten schutz vor der infektion
geben sollte
wir sind noch mal in göttingen bei frau
professor hungers in ihren
aufklärungsgesprächen noch mal die frage
frau
wissen sie welche berechtigten zweifel
der menschen also würden auch sie sagen
da weiß man über nebenwirkungen noch zu
wenig und da habe ich auch noch nicht
alle antworten alle antworten hat man
natürlich noch nicht zu langzeit
nebenwirkungen einfach weil es den
impfstoff noch nicht so lange gibt da
werden wir jeden tag schlauer aber nur
um genau einen tag im prinzip das muss
man beobachten
aber wir wissen dass nebenwirkungen nach
impfstoffen oft sehr schnell auftreten
und dass das bei diesem impfstoff eher
selten ist das wissen wir eben auch
schon das ist schon einer der recht gut
verträglich erscheint auch wenn er kurz
zeit impfreaktionen zeigt dir zeigen
dass sich der körper mit dem impfstoff
auseinandersetzt was erwünscht ist
bescheiden doch schwerere nebenwirkungen
selten bis sehr selten zu sein und die
nachbeobachtungszeit bei zigtausend
geimpften menschen die es da schon gibt
gibt uns doch da eine recht gute
sicherheit oder relevanten ausgezeichnet
wirksam der ist ausgezeichnet wirksam
vielleicht von anderen weiß man dass
auch schon oder wir werden es in
weiteren wochen wissen was sind frage
auch eine ecke von hirschhausen
begründete nachfragen und begründete
sorgen der menschen
warum sie wissen dass beipackzettel
maßgeblich für juristen geschrieben
werden und nicht mehr mensch stimmt ja
ja würden zum beispiel idiotischer weise
reingeschrieben man darf nur fünf dosen
aus der pulle nehmen wobei praktiker
sagen da kann man auch sechs und sieben
leute mit impfen ja das ist quatsch dass
man da auf 20 prozent des wirkstoffs für
das ich schon geschieht ja endlich wird
über darüber gesprochen in amerika da
steht es im beipackzettel deutschland
noch nicht und so also es gibt eine
menge ungereimtheiten zum beispiel steht
ja auch dass schwangere eben erst mal
nicht geben werden sollen daraus hat
sich im internet ein gerücht entwickelt
dass es irgendwie dass man davon
unfruchtbar werden könnte oder eben
bezeugung unfähig da fehlt in
deutschland komplett eine institution
die sich darum kümmert die passion wird
sagen sich auf sehr dubiosen seiten
tummeln und da manchmal millionen
menschen erreichen dass dort mit den mit
waffengleichheit sozusagen eine schnelle
eingreiftruppe das wort hier
argumentiert weil die leute werden nicht
automatisch auf die seite vom
robert-koch-institut und von der
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung gehen oder von ard und zdf ja
auch oft faktenchecks anbieten oder
korrektiv punkt org oder auch
volksverhetzer und so da gibt's tolle
seiten aber die kennen maßgeblich die
insider und deswegen wünsche ich mir
sehr dass wir sozusagen auch darüber
nachdenken wie die geschwindigkeit die
soziale medien heute in der
kommunikation vorgeben auf amtlicher
seite im moment überhaupt kein condor
hat und das ist ein echtes manko und das
haben wir jetzt ein jahr beobachtet und
da braucht es auch eine antwort und zwar
eine schnelle und eine kommunikative und
wenn wir claudia kade es noch mal
politisch anschauen
dieses thema impfen da gibt es also die
israelis und die amerikaner und es gibt
die briten die schneller sind als die
deutschen die schneller sind als wir
was müsste der anspruch der deutschen
politik sein und was glauben sie werden
wir davon schaffen also der anspruch
muss sein nachdem würding der regierung
ja selbst das ist eine
jahrhundertaufgabe eine historische
impfaktion die wir jetzt hier vor uns
haben muss die antwort eigentlich sein
dass das organisatorisch zumindest im
land wenn wir jetzt mal die beschaffung
außen vor lassen dass es im land dann
wenigstens funktioniert also wie sie
sagen überzeugungsarbeit statt zwang ich
finde eine impfpflicht wäre wirklich
eine kapitulationserklärung der
regierung
wenn man statt überzeugungsarbeit auf
zwang setzt und auch alle möglichen
versprechungen des halben kabinetts
übern haufen wirft das ist das eine
auch überhaupt finde ich die rhetorik
die von einigen ministerpräsidenten an
den tag gelegt wird in bestimmten
krisenphasen oder momenten in der
pandemie sehr problematisch kretzschmar
davon gesprochen wir müssen autoritärer
sein
markus söder definiert jetzt wer sich
als opfer fühlen kann in der pandemie
und aus seiner sicht sind das nur die
nur in anführungszeichen die
verstorbenen
wo man überhaupt außer acht lässt mich
vielleicht ja die ganzen pandemie
beschränkungen und alles weitere nach
sich ziehen also das gehört alles dazu
zu einem krisen management das die
menschen ja mitten im muss es ist ja
nicht so dass die bürger allein dafür
verantwortlich sind wie diese pandemie
bekämpft sondern es ist immer ein
zusammenwirken aus wissenschaft politik
und bürgern und deswegen halte ich eben
diese diese diese ja diese autoritäre
gedrückt für sehr problematisch und wenn
herr kretschmer sagt wir müssen die
maßnahmen verschärfen weil wir die
zahlen nicht runter bekommen weil die
mutationen der viren jetzt auch noch
droht welche maßnahmen denn er sprach
eben gerade vom 15 kilometer radius
ehrlich gesagt die ministerpräsidenten
nach der ersten nach der vorigen
merkel-runde sind reihenweise
ausgestiegen aus diesen 15 kilometer
beschränkung bewegungsradius
beschränkung weil das unsinnig ist in
sachsen haben wir damals
nachrecherchiert das wird überhaupt nur
stichprobenartig in sachsen kontrolliert
man kann sozusagen zum zum wintersport
nach kanada fahren aber nicht zum
nachbarwahlkreis also da müsste man sich
mal überlegen
schotten wir tourismusgebiete ab pnv
vielleicht nicht dichtmachen das trifft
die arbeitende bevölkerung die sich
vielleicht nicht unbedingt jeder
autofahrt leisten kann sondern mehr mehr
züge einsetzen
also ich glaube da muss man ein bisschen
intelligenter arbeiten um nicht wieder
so ein effekt zu haben wie beherbergungs
verbot wo auch die akzeptanz sofort
zusammengefallen ist in der bevölkerung
und immer mehr solcher kipppunkte sie
tun natürlich nicht gut die bewirtung
überhaupt nicht gut und bevor wir jetzt
genau über diesen verschärfung des lockt
uns noch mal reden was ist der
bevölkerung nach ihrem gefühl eckart von
hirschhausen eigentlich noch zuzumuten
also bei den menschen löst natürlich ein
teil der beschlüsse tatsächlich auch
echte verwunderung aus weil man nicht
versteht warum man sich jetzt nur noch
mit eigenem menschen treffen soll aber
im betrieb die ganze zeit noch acht
stunden zusammen club kann das jetzt
noch mal eine weile durchgehalten werden
wenn wir so kommunizieren die wir bisher
kommuniziert die politik meine ich mit
dem beschuldigung es ist es ist schwer
zu sagen
ich möchte erstmal sagen dass die
allermeisten menschen sich überraschend
vernünftig verhalten und wir natürlich
auch mediales verzerren des element drin
haben wenn wir jedem der die extreme
meinung hat immer eine mikrofon vor die
nase halten das hatten wir schon bei
anderen themen auch ich würde mir aber
wünschen dass man zum beispiel auch mehr
über seine wortwahl nachdenkt was heißt
denn privilegien für geimpfte also ist
eine rückkehr zur normalität zum
beispiel oder einen aufheben von
grundrechts einschränkungen ist ja etwas
wünschenswert ist und dann meine
sonderrechte oder was klares einer
grippe pausieren
ich würde mir bei dem solidargedanken
zum beispiel wünschen was sie gerade
völlig richtig angesprochen haben worauf
verzichten gerade jugendliche ja die mit
der schule fertig sind ja eigentlich
aufbrechen wollen da die kommen im
moment sehr wenig vor
die leisten im moment etwas zum schutz
ihrer großeltern man sich großartig
finde könnte man sich vorstellen dass
die großeltern dann im gegenzug wenn wir
durch diese pandemie durch sind auch
etwas solidarisches tun zum beispiel
nicht kreuzfahrten machen nicht
sozusagen aufholenden konsum machen
sondern die viel größere krise ernst
nehme ich die klimakrise die panne ist
für mich ein zeit und energiefresser die
wir wir bräuchten diese ressourcen um
die größte gesundheitsgefahren mich die
klimakatastrophe anzugehen und ich habe
große sorge dass das dann im nachhinein
heißt ja jetzt haben wir keine keine
ressourcen oder dafür jetzt müssen wir
erst mal wieder alles wieder normal
machen die welt vorher war nicht normal
wir schlittern in diesem jahrzehnt auf
die entscheidende phase zu in der sich
entscheiden ob menschen überhaupt auf
dieser erde bleiben können atmen leben
was haben die harmonie heißt sobald ich
1000 hitzetod im letzten jahr gehabt das
waren sehr viel mehr sozusagen über
sterblichkeit im sommer als ankommt hat
keiner drüber geredet wir sind das land
mit den dritthäufigsten hitzetod nach
china und indien
warum kommt das in den medien nicht vor
das kommt in den medien vor und kam in
den medien vor aber jetzt jüngst in
dieser pandemie ein bisschen weh aber
der gedanke ist natürlich schön
und vielleicht werden großeltern den
auch schon gedacht haben dass es jetzt
dann im sommer nicht als erstes die
nächste kreuzfahrt braucht sondern dass
man vielleicht über etwas anderes tun
nachdenken kann was man der gesellschaft
zurück gibt herr lauterbach locker und
verschärfung des londons
wie lange glauben sie ist den menschen
das noch zuzumuten wenn wir sich so
widersprechende regelungen angeboten
haben und eine solche distanz und den
politikern
also ich finde es zunächst einmal sehr
problematisch dass hier in berlin
regelungen beschlossen werden dann sind
die ministerpräsidenten kaum zu hause
angekommen und sagen das setzen wir
nicht um so unsinnig wie das ist das
kann nicht so kommuniziert werden das
nicht richtig
man muss die grundgeschichte erzählen
also wieso denken wir jetzt darüber nach
den locker und noch einmal zu
verschärfen
wir sind im moment eigentlich in ein
wettrennen eingetreten und zwar des
weiteren ist einfach das also ob es uns
gelingt mit verschärften lockdown die
jetztige welle schnell genug zu beenden
und in den griff zu bekommen bevor die
neue mutation kommt oder ob die neue
mutation schneller da ist als dass wir
durch diesen doktoren durch sind muss
der bevölkerung ganz ehrlich sagen wenn
es uns nicht gelingt die jetztige welle
zu beherrschen
nicht zu stoppen durch verschärfung ohne
verschärfung wird das nicht gelingen
dann kommen die aus dem loch dann so
schnell gar nicht mehr raus war dann
kommen wir aus einem lock down in ein
wachstum hinein bei lockdown bei wenn
wir jetzt die neuen mutanten schon
flächendeckend hätten dann würden wir
exponentielles wachstum also massives
wachstum mit schneller überlastung der
intensiv kapazitäten und der tragödie
die damit einhergeht im lockdown sehen
und das muss verhindert werden und nur
wenn ich diese gesamt geschichte erzähle
dann wäre es halt dann verstehen die
menschen ganz gehen die menschen auch
mit dann ziehen die menschen mit die
müssen erklärt bekommen was ist denn
jetzt die neue situation was ist das
besondere
und wenn man das nicht versteht dann ist
man auch also dann denkt man medialen
sagen so die anderen sagen so und
vielleicht ist ja auch alles gar nicht
nötig dann ziehen die menschen nicht mit
wenn man es gut erklärt bin ich sicher
gehen mit so und dann schauen wir noch
mal nach sachsen und bevor wir zu
michael kretschmann nochmal schalten ist
vielleicht wichtig zu sagen dass die
zahlen in diesem bundesland wirklich
erschreckend sind sowohl in bezug auf
die instanzen als auch in bezug auf die
toten und das hat eben noch nichts mit
den mutationen zu tun
bedrückende bilder aus dresden
krematorien am anschlag
zu viele tote in zu kurzer zeit wir
suchen jetzt nach krematorien weiter weg
von sachsen und noch leichen einäschern
zu können die inzidenz blatt hoch über
400 allein in meißen der impfstart hat
luft nach oben
viertletzter ist sachsen im vergleich
pro 1000 einwohner meldet der freistaat
8,5 geimpfte 13 große impfzentren
starteten am montag
wir haben wirklich alle energie
reingesteckt dass wir ab heute
kontinuierlich in allen impfzentren an
den start gehen
herr kretschmann die lage ist schon
jetzt sehr angespannt in ihrem land und
das ist noch freundlich formuliert der
lkw chef sagt heute die maßnahmen müssen
verschärft werden
dieser lockdown ist aus seiner sicht gar
keiner wo sehen sie noch potenzial über
das hinaus was sie gerade schon gesagt
haben muss beispielsweise die wirtschaft
heruntergefahren werden weil jeder noch
kontakte am arbeitsplatz hat ja ich
meine das muss dieses land miteinander
ausdiskutieren ein stück weit also wir
müssen dass am ende politisch
entscheiden welche kosten können wir
tragen und es muss am ende
ökonomisch so sein dass dieses land
nicht dabei kaputt geht und von daher
denke ich brauchte es man kann es mal
nach hirschhausen sagen nicht man kann
ja das wort nicht muss das wort ich
verwenden verschärfung sondern
konsequentere umsetzung
die sind die dinge die wir jetzt uns
vorgenommen haben alle so ins werk
gesetzt dass tatsächlich kontakte
vermieden werden dass mobilität
zurückgenommen wird dann würde ich sagen
gibt es an vielen stellen
nachbesserungsbedarf
ich wäre auch nicht so schnell dabei
diese 15 kilometer so beiseite zu
schieben und ich sagen wir haben
sie ist nicht nur logisch sie ist sehr
gut nach kontrollierbar und sie wird
sehr gut eingehalten weil für jeden klar
ist von meinem wohnbereich aus so können
sich jetzt mit dem kopf schütteln aber
ich lebe in dem land in dem es seit
wochen eingehalten wird
15 km von meiner wohnung aus kann ich
sport treiben kann
einkaufen gehen und das ist für die
polizei beispielsweise sehr leicht zu
kontrollieren ob jemand im erzgebirge
ist wo die leute herkommen
solche dinge muss man jetzt machen wir
haben über die pflegeheim gesprochen wir
haben jetzt auch noch mal in sachsen die
kantinen geschlossen weil wir auch da
gesehen haben das könnte ein ort sein an
dem die infektion überspringen das
entscheidende ist dass uns allen klar
ist kontakte vermeiden mobilität
vermeiden
zu hause bleiben das ist das a und o
und dann ist das muss man hier schaffen
ihn noch mal die frage hängt also
stichwort 15 kilometer hängt das
ansteckungsrisiko davon ab wohin ich
fahre
nein es hängt ja eher davon ab wie viele
leute ich da und deswegen nutze die ich
gerade weil mir jemand aus der pflege
berichtete dass ein immobil kam um die
alten menschen in der einrichtung zu
impfen
aber die pflegefachkräfte wurden
aufgefordert zu einem impfzentrum in
einer stadt zu fahren was weiter als 15
kilometer war
und da denke ich auch dass das geht doch
nicht also das sind das ist immer wieder
wenn man in der praxis guckt denkt man
die hindernisse sind nicht ideologisch
die sind praktisch das in amerika wird
in apotheken geimpft und deswegen für
alle die sich wirklich viel pflege
engagieren wollen ab heute ist er auf
der der pflege petitions appell beim
stern mit vielen deutsche pflegerat mit
vielen institutionen gesunden erde
gesunde menschen ist auch dabei also
wenn sie wenn sie was für die pflege tun
wollen unterschreiben sie 20.000 gleich
noch mal vielleicht noch mal ein einsatz
wie sie können wir können natürlich auch
nicht das spiel machen dass wir jeden
einzelfall wenn mal was schief gegangen
ist generalisieren
also denn in der mehrzahl der
pflegeheime läuft es so dass das team
kommt dass dort die bewohner geimpft
werden und gleichzeitig mit das personal
und das ist darauf findet man natürlich
und werde es auch mal anders läuft muss
man sagen das ist nicht optimal gewesen
muss besser werden aber wir besprechen
gerade in dieser pandemie in der so
vieles besonders ist so vieles neu ist
in dem die aufgabe so gewaltig ist immer
gleich den stab wegen jedem einzelfall
über alles ich glaube dieses land hat
macht es gut wir haben noch luft nach
oben zur verbesserung das muss jetzt
auch passieren aber
es lebt auch davon dass wir alle
mitmachen und ein positives grund
verhältnis zu dem ganzen haben so dann
hätten wir das vielleicht mal in
ansätzen geklärt positives grund
verhältnis frau gerade noch mal die
frage nach den firmen und den betrieben
also in das privatleben der menschen
wird massiv hineinregiert aber in den
werkhallen in den fabriken in den keine
ahnung auf den baustellen hat man das
gefühl dass in rechtsfreien zonen da
laufen die menschen noch rum und haben
keine masken und ackern und sind acht
stunden nebeneinander wer meinen weg
aber auch erstmal sich das verbot
sondern erst mal tatsächlich hygiene
vorschriften umsetzen also ich würde
tatsächlich nicht gleich mit dem
pauschalen hammer kommen dann werden wir
auch erlebt dass gerichte das auch ganz
schnell wieder einkassieren wenn es
nicht zielgenau und nicht
nachvollziehbar und nicht gerechtfertigt
ist deswegen würde ich erst mal setzen
auf die gene konzepte home office wo es
geht auf jeden fall auch da den da
wirklich eindruck verschärfen
tatsächlich ben home office möglich ist
auf jeden fall aber ein es gibt es
gerade so eine petition oder so eine
summe in den sozialen medien so eine
forderung die komplette wirtschaft
stoppen jetzt das hat er mir was mit
marktwirtschaft und kapitalismus kritik
glaube ich zu tun als mit dem
tatsächlichen pandemie bekämpfung das
thema die wollen ja dann auch da gibt es
diese krankenhäuser dazu zu
verstaatlichen und alle hatten aber es
gibt ein sprechender bekannten den
vorschlag auch von den sogenannten
modellieren
sie sagen wenn wir in einen harten 2
oder 3 wöchigen lockdown gingen und
wirklich jeder zu hause bliebe dann wäre
das virus tot
das ist mathematik aber offensichtlich
nicht das leben wir haben uns für einen
anderen weg entschieden bisher auf jeden
fall wird aber von genau diesen
modellieren natürlich die frage gestellt
sollten wir jetzt in einen kompletten
locker und herr lauterbach ehrlich wir
sagen muss man sagen dass wir im moment
das beste ich glaube nicht dass du die
situation sonst früh genug in den griff
bekommen wenn wir in einen teil locker
und bleiben dann dauert das zu lange bis
wir auf diese ziele incidents runter
sind wir brauchen erzielen student sie
unter dem ziel liegt was wir jetzt
verfolgen auf 25 oder ähnliches müssen
wir runter und das erreichen wir nicht
rechtzeitig daher wäre wahrscheinlich
jetzt an
strem harter lockt auch mit schließung
vieler betriebe und home office also
angeordneter sächsische schweiz der
landkreis hat knapp 500 wie kommen sie
da jetzt auf 25
also wenn alles wenn man geschichte oder
grafen zu hause bleiben muss und also
kann nur mit sp2 maske zum einkaufen
gehen und es kommen noch arztbesuche es
wird nur das nötigste gemacht dann das
ist ja das also besondere wäre etwas was
exponentiell wächst wenn es keine
kontakte mehr gibt dann geht es auch
exponenten exponentiell runter das heißt
wir kämen werden wir wirklich hart
durchgreifen würden
das immer wieder gezeigt wurden dann
kämen wir auch sehr sehr schnell von
diese zahlen runter und das wäre
wahrscheinlich jetzt die bessere
strategie
herr kretschmer kurze einschätzung
vorstellbar in ihren augen das auch das
einen plan b sein kann wissen sie werden
sie das als gedankenexperiment machen
mal 14 tage drei wochen nichts keiner
bewegt sich mehr
dann stimmt das dann ist dieses virus
tod aber in der praxis ist dann auch die
deutsche volkswirtschaft oder die
europäische und viele viele unternehmen
haben durch und deswegen muss man das
ganze so machen dass es auf der einen
seite ökonomisch funktioniert kann der
gesundheit von der medizin funktioniert
und ich würde uns raten jetzt wirklich
nicht in extreme position zu denken
sondern das praktisch mögliche jetzt zu
tun wir dafür brauchen wir die
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
ich habe gesagt das war ein fehler
autoritäre maßnahmen für mich ging es
damals um die autorität des staates
nachdem wir wochenlang diskutiert haben
uns den mund fusselig geredet haben 80
prozent der deutschen mit gemacht haben
aber 20 prozent abseits gestanden haben
corona geleugnet haben und diese 20
prozent reichen im zweifel in dieser
pandemie um das ganze zum kippen zu
bringen
jetzt geht es darum konsequent die dinge
durchzusetzen das werden wir nächsten
woche denke ich noch machen wenn die
menschen dabei mitmachen schaffen wir es
in einigen wochen die zahlen nach unten
zu bekommen die krankenhäuser zu
entlasten
das muss unser ziel sein wir brauchen
starke unternehmen um auch die kosten
dieser pandemie wieder zu fragen sollen
das argument genau karl lauterbach
schüttelt den kopf und sagt wir könnten
das schaffen und wir könnten es
durchhalten frage nach göttingen
frau mit was denken sie worauf wird die
politik sich verständigen was wäre in
ihren augen in dieser situation eine r
tragbare lösung ist ausgesprochen
schwierig zu beantworten weil es eben so
pauschal gar nicht geht als gerade die
rede von einem ganz harten lockdown war
habe ich mich gefragt wer denn dann die
leute in den krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen zum beispiel versorgen soll
die zumindest müssen zur arbeit kommen
im supermarkt möchten sie auch trotzdem
was vorfinden und die kinder von unserem
pflegepersonal hier müssen auch irgendwo
bleiben also in der radikalität wie das
postuliert wird geht das gar nicht schon
immer sinnvoller
bewegung bewegung weiter zu reduzieren
aber es gibt ganz viele ausnahmen in
diesem system und auch die ausnahmen
schaffen schäden die man letztlich
abwägen muss darum ist das so schwierig
dort eine lösung zu finden
ich denke weniger mobilität und weniger
bewegungen sind wichtig aber jetzt zu
sagen wir rühren uns alle überhaupt
nicht mehr ist einfach nicht realistisch
und von daher auch nicht hilfreich und
die meisten ansteckungen finden in
familien statt das heißt zuhause ist
auch immer noch jemand anders ja dann
ist es natürlich gut wenn ich auch noch
außenstehende angesteckt werden aber das
drückt auch nicht die sache von
vorneherein auf null so dass das eine
schwierige aufgabe für die politik und
auch für jeden einzelnen menschen bleibt
absolut richtig karl lauterbach sagte
gerade noch er würde genau die von ihnen
genannten natürlich aus nehmen weil sie
einfach lebens und überlebenswichtig
sind es bleibt genau so wie sie gerade
gesagt haben frau professor omas es ist
so groß und es ist so schwierig dass wir
noch viel darüber nachdenken und die
politik noch viel zu entscheiden hat wir
sehen uns nächsten donnerstag wieder
weil wir jetzt hier einfach mal einen
punkt machen müssen
wir wollen uns
wie immer gleiche stelle gleiche welle
dann wieder mit ihnen verabreden und
markus lanz hat unter anderem noch heute
armin laschet zu gast das verfolgen sie
sicherlich interessiert und ansonsten
bleibt nur noch zu wünschen
passen sie gut auf sich auf bleiben sie
gesund es wird jetzt die nächsten wochen
auch noch nicht wirklich besser
vielen dank ihn ein wieder danke
[Musik]